And now, Asap SCIENCE presents:
100 digits of pi!
3 . 1 4 1 5 9
This is pi,
followed by
2 6 5 3 5 8 9
*circumference over diameter!*
7 9 then 3 2 3
OMG! Can't you see?
8 4 6 2 6 4 3
and now we're on a spree!
38 and 32
Now we're blue! Oh who knew?
7950 and then a 2
88 and 41
So much fun!
Now we run!
9 7 1 6 9 3 9 9
3 7 51
HALF WAY DONE‼
0 5 8
Now don't be late!
2 0 9
Where's the wine?
7 4
It's on the floor!
Then 9 4 4 5 9
2 3 0 we gotta go!
7 8 we can't wait!
1 6 4 0 6 2 8
*We're almost near the end, keep going!*
62 we're getting through!
0 8 9! 9 on time!
8 6 2 8 0 3 4
There's only a few more!
8 2
then 5 3
42 11 7 0 and 67
We're done!
Was that fun?
Learning random degits so that you can brag to your friends!
Thank you guys for watching!
If you wanna get the song, we'll put links for iTunes and anywhere else in the description that you can check out.
Study it, brag to your friends, okay?
And make sure you subscribe to this channel for new science, weekly videos every Thursday and we'll see you next week!
Seeya!